thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a youthful
wild ride with Stevo we've got mod Sun
his new album God saved the teen is just
out his best friend Machine Gun Kelly
just made a movie with him they they
wrote it together he's engaged to Avril
Lavigne he's got a very fresh and
Youthful view of the world and man at
the end the last like half hour is just
straight crazy talking about addiction
and alcoholism and that part is juicier
than hell do not miss the last half hour
of this podcast
let's get into it yeah buddy yeah dude
apologies for the delay what the [__]
you talking about you're a minute early
yeah that's [__] late as [__] you're
a minute early birdie
all right
yeah dude I love you bro Dad love you
too man it's so good to see you again we
met briefly one time but that's it
that's right
okay
um that says two I'm gonna [__] run
with it here we go
ladies and gentlemen mod Sun I'm here I
made it on my favorite podcast of the
world I love you dude yeah I uh have
never had anybody celebrity or
non-celebrity alike expressed to me the
kind of passion for this podcast as you
have it's not a joke when I say it I was
just telling them I spent so much time
in my car because I live like really
deep in Malibu it takes an hour and a
half to get anywhere
um and this is like all I listen to bro
yeah I really do I've probably seen I
mean I know you have like die hard
viewers but I'm one of them and I've
probably seen close to all the episodes
dude including the last one that you
just dropped are the death row guy yeah
yeah heavy it's heavy heavy how the the
comments on our death row inmate podcast
I I saw literally like one like how dare
you give this guy a platform yeah he
committed a crime 600 years ago yeah
right like they're like this guy gets me
on a celebrity podcast but his victim is
still six feet under and that's not
right yeah yeah it's like man I mean
granted you know he did murder somebody
he did but he also was 16 and it's like
17. he's 17 and if somebody's gonna get
another chance it's like but dude you
know when you know what's crazy is that
that podcast got uh dinged by YouTube as
well for what it said you know not uh
suitable for ads
so if you don't know what we're talking
about it's because you're probably on
YouTube and they don't want you to see
it so look up through inmate yeah
yeah I thought it was really interesting
well thank you man thank you and that's
like what's really cool about your
podcast is that you do stuff like that
well it's the first time I know you're
you're passionate about that yeah you
know dude I love it yeah I super love it
I mean you kind of got me into all that
good well I uh I I really genuinely
appreciated when you when you told me
that we might as well explain we were at
uh what is it it was a Premiere and
advanced screening yeah for uh the movie
that you wrote yeah and uh and then MGK
directed it yeah me me tell us yeah me
and Kelsey directed it Colson Baker
Colson Baker which I would have never
called him that in my entire life good I
can't call him Colson dude what do you
call them Kells cows do it yes we've
known each other for like 12 years and
like I didn't even know he had a first
name until like three years ago right
okay but he introduces himself as Kel uh
Coulson I know
yeah yeah he does now he's uh Dwayne
Johnson over here yeah
I will never I will never introduce
myself just I I go by mod that's it mod
I hate the name I was born with what's
your name we were born with
oh dude Derek Derek all right okay the
reason I hated it though is because it's
spelled d-e-r-e-k and then all the time
in school though the teacher would say
Derek and I'm like there is no ick in my
name I don't want to hear ick every
second so I just hated it my whole life
I hate it we always look more like a mod
than a Derek thank you that's the
greatest compliment and we're done thank
you all right as a wrap baby we uh he
used to always laugh still do sometimes
would say like if a guy just is a
disaster does not have his act together
we'll say what a Daryl a Daryl yeah like
kind of like short for Derek okay okay
yeah I do know Daryl's exactly how do
they act bro yeah
legit legit legit it's pretty funny if
you think of it that way like naming
your kid Daryl
I always thinking about that like a like
a young kid named Gretchen like it's
they're just so strange to name him that
yeah
um so help me remember what was the name
of that movie good morning good morning
and morning it's spelled with you and we
actually shot it coming up here driving
up this Canyon we actually shot at the
house that we shot it at is like blocks
away from here right so I was over here
every day for a like two months at five
a.m and how did that movie perform it
was on Netflix it is no it's not on
Netflix
um it's on uh Amazon Prime it just got
added to American Airlines
yeah I mean it was our it was our first
like real
real feature Movie experience you know
we shot a short film before that called
um downfalls High which was like a short
film for Machine Gun Kelly's album
tickets to my downfall yeah we made like
kind of like a rock opera kind of thing
right
um and that did really well so we wrote
this script and uh we were going this
was before that short film for the album
came out we wrote that script and we
were going around town and me and cows
would show up into like these producers
offices and we would go back and forth
reading the script in front of them the
whole thing acting out each character
and uh everyone was like yo we really
like the script but there's no way in
hell we're gonna let you direct this
like you guys do not know what the [__]
you're doing at all and uh and then the
short film for his album came out and
then some people saw that and they're
like
all right like maybe maybe we will let
you do this so we found a production
company
um David aired you know David air I do
not director he did like training day
and yeah Suicide Squad just like the
real done a lot
um his production I love you his
production company
um picked it up and was like we're gonna
let you guys do this this is our first
time in like dude I learned so much and
it was uh it was being uh an artist
mainly you know music is my main vehicle
right working on a movie was the closest
thing I felt to working a real job since
ninth grade that that checks out to me
it was like you're waking up at the same
time every day early morning long days
wait homework sitting I mean
pre-production I'm in an office sitting
behind a desk at nine to five yeah and
it was just like a crazy it was a really
crazy learning experience what was the
budget for the movie it's like three and
a half mil wow that's a lot it's a lot
but in standards a movie it's not like
crazy but um we got really lucky the
cast is amazing in it which we were like
all friends with and so they kind of
like out of the kindness of their heart
were like all right we'll support you
idiots that don't know what you're doing
right yeah I mean when I say that's a
lot you're right in the terms of movies
that's nothing yeah it's nothing right
but it's a lot of money I mean the movie
business is like the highest Stakes
gambling it's 100 100 dude and what
people don't know when they hear like
the how much money a movie brought in
that half of that number goes to the
movie theaters yeah you're only starting
out with half of it yeah and then
whatever the budget was forget about
that because the budget is almost always
less than what's called p a promotion
and advertising right they spend more on
the Billboards the commercials the
trailers than they do on the movie
itself so yeah can you explain that
again what did you say half of the
budget goes to the movie theaters or
half of the income how would you see it
grossed 100 million that means that all
the movie theaters that it was at
probably took 15.50 if it grossed 100
million then 50 million went to the
movie theaters and then the other half
the other 50 million went to uh whatever
the studio wow I wonder where the profit
is on that because I thought movie
theaters just made their money they
generally broke even and then made their
that's why popcorn is so [__]
expensive for like Coca-Cola because
it's like they weren't making that much
money off of it yeah you know when you
put it that way too I think movie
theater is not that bad of a business
honestly I don't think it is either even
though you go into a movie theater now
and there's five people in it right but
I still think it's all right
movie theater was a pretty pretty dope
business well it's interesting because
like when I travel one of the things I
like to do different countries I go to
is I go see a movie in a different
country and I went all over like
southeast Asia to different movie
theaters and uh popcorn there was like
two bucks so like you know I'm like [__]
how is it so expensive and I think it's
I think I think they might make a lot of
money in the United States because they
do make it's the concessions right I
mean I don't know what's going on with
movie theaters these days but but your
guy's movie wasn't really in movie
theaters right it opened in like I want
to say like 15. okay
um and so that was cool like in like
kind of like me and Machine Gun Kelly is
like a market so to say right come from
Minnesota he's from Cleveland so like
Midwest stuff and there was like in LA
opening and stuff like that do you have
a sense of how the movie performed
financially not at all okay not at all I
have I I make money on it on the back
end yet no no
uh I haven't made anything on the back
end of Jackass forever okay so I've got
a long ways to go
I'll be waiting I'll hit you up in 10
years and let you know
um but but uh as far as like you know
it's really like a stoner comedy and
kind of
um the hopes going into it was make like
something that's more of like a cult
classic you know that gets better over
time sure
um we were at Scott and I at the the
movie that's where where you introduced
yourself to yeah tell me you loved the
podcast we were thoroughly enjoying the
movie but we're both sober nerds yeah
and uh the little screening room that it
was in like I just got so smoked out
I know we're there we're so close to
getting kicked out yeah we're so close
to getting kicked I was just like dude I
can't hear like I don't I just like
I don't care if people drink alcohol
around me because like that's not
entering my body you know like when
people are smoking weed and I'm
breathing it in that's like second hand
I understand that now I can't I I
understand that like I actually do as
like as like uh from like 16 years old
until like two years ago I was like I
can't smoke what the [__] you talking
about you're getting high and now I'm
like okay yeah I do understand right
yeah I remember I remember we left there
and I was like [__] that was gnarly and
then I kind of was like I kind of wish I
was hot like I was like I wish I got
stuck in the eye off that you know it's
like a free lap yeah yeah I mean I don't
I don't know how high you actually
I don't know how high you'd actually get
from that but uh just the idea of it and
what's most upsetting to me about it is
how much I love the smell of weed how
much how much I frankly miss being able
to smoke weed yeah like if I could smoke
weed I would love that's the one thing I
miss doing I totally I would love to be
able to smoke weed I just know that I
can't yeah yeah so yeah whatever I'm
kind of there now too all right
um now uh
so you got the the movie that was fun
music's your biggest thing yeah if I saw
on your Instagram you you just uh made
the leap to a larger size venue yeah it
has that tour begun yet no it starts uh
February 19th so in like exactly a month
right now all right yeah February 19th
um I think it's 27 shows about 27 shows
wow yeah it's like a six-week tour
um which is kind of a long one but yeah
I mean dude I've been doing this since I
was 16 years old like been on stage so
over 40 now 35 all right probably 35
every year is a trophy for me
um and uh dude I grew up playing in punk
bands bro playing to literally my mom
and my sister were the crowd nice
um give me some punk bangs that you love
well I mean like I was I was a true pop
punk kid okay like that was my that was
my real
everything when I started you know it
was like 182. I mean blink 22 was like
the Gateway yeah yeah okay so I played
drums and bands like my whole life
growing up and um I mean like yo like
drive-through records I don't know if
you've ever heard of drive through
records but they had bands like Newfound
Glory the starting line
um Alistair like these real like the the
real like heart of pop punk guy look at
it okay um so like those were those were
the bands that like I really got into
and that was like a Gateway obviously
into like the where where that comes
from before that
um but that that was my true First Love
was drums in bands doing that and I
played the same venues like I was in a
band called four letter lie that was the
first band I was signed in where I
played drums and it was like uh
kind of like a post-hardcore band like
screaming and singing okay double kicked
breakdown [__] like that
um those venues that I played in with
that band that were like 500 cap I had
played those venues pretty much for like
12 years straight
and finally now leaping up to like 1500
cap venues and that's 1500 standing yeah
yeah right yeah which is a lot yeah yeah
super super a lot I mean and I'm just
like the gratitude that I have to be 35
and hitting like what I look at is like
big inclines in my career that's kind of
the story that I like want to leave
behind for any kids out there that are
involved in art or just in life in
general like life doesn't stop in your
20s
did I tell you this guy's got a youthful
view of the world or what the guy thinks
he's over the hill at age 35. it's
insane he's his message is life isn't
over after your 20s I'm thinking dude
I'm almost 50 over here and I'm vibrant
I'm full of life you know why it's
because I drink water man it turns out
water is really good for you and this
water company liquid death is really
good for the world why because they're
infinitely recyclable tall boy cans are
infinitely recyclable it's time to bring
an end to plastic people it's time to
drink more water throw away less plastic
and save the world man because the world
needs to be young too and get this this
company liquid death they make these
just great merch items like the severed
hand collab they did with Martha Stewart
greatest candle of all time all their
just super super fun and cool and the
Wild Ride listeners get 20 off your
first apparel purchase how about that
folks 20 off your first apparel purchase
if you go to liquiddeath.com
Stevo now let's get back to it oh wow
okay well when did it happen for you
when it was like was there a plateau and
you're like what the [__] am I doing and
then it just blew up it was kind of like
a yeah it was like a stagnant line that
was kind of just like a straight across
for how long dude for for 10 years you
know for real when I when I quit playing
drums in a band I still play drums this
day on my music but when I quit playing
drums in the band and started doing what
I'm doing now mod Sun as like the solo
artist
um that was around the age of 21. so now
being 35 so you know like that long
um and there was little like Peaks but
it was mostly like a very slow rise
there was never any like real going down
where I felt like I should quit I've
never really felt like that anyway that
that it was time to quit you know
um I've always like my favorite artist
in the whole world is Bob Dylan so like
that's who I look at as someone who's
like 80 years old still yeah releasing
albums and going on tours so I kind of
always looked at that as like the
standard of what an artist should strive
for you know I remember when Knoxville
told us he wanted to make a fourth
Jackass movie yeah I was like I I didn't
get it I just thought man we are just
too old for this
the more I chewed on it I uh I remember
like responding to this whole group
thread with the whole entire uh the
whole cast on it I wrote back like dude
if we're gonna do this we should have
the the opening sequence set to a
rolling stone song you know like yeah
but well I I even had one that I thought
would be rad too of course I mean how do
you feel about that now the whole like
you can't be too old for sure I love it
I like I love it
um I've been terrified of it and now
like I'm just in what way terrified like
just just like when your body can handle
um what I don't like is that
um
I feel like being old in our society is
a party Foul yeah it's party Foul yeah
but nobody wants to think about their
mortality nobody wants to consider that
they're gonna end up dead nobody wants
to even think about they're gonna get
old and so to see an old person it
forces people to be reminded of their
mortality and they don't like that so
people don't want to look at old people
and at my core I am the gnarliest
detention [__] of all time and all I
want is for people to look at me so the
idea of becoming old wanting people to
look at you being an attention [__] but
at the same time because you're old
you're a party pal it's like that's the
ultimate like Terror to me it's such a
nightmare see and like that's kind of
what I was just touching on is like
that's such a true like ISM of right now
and I really want to rebuild that I want
to be the part of her building that I
really do because because I feel like
I feel like too many people think that
if you haven't made it in your 20s then
you need to give up you need to try
something else and I think that that I
just I can't stand that and that's why
I'm so proud to say like I am 35 years
old I don't know
well that that's the thing in in like
all the motivational books I've read
they say that most people like most
billionaires or millionaires didn't hit
their stride till they're like 40 or 50
because they stopped trying to get [__]
yeah and so they wasted all that energy
up until 40. like trying to get later
like all the energy trying to get laid
is like and then once they got married
or once they settled down like KFC like
or who you know the guy who did Chrysler
Walter P Christ like all these people
started blowing up in their 50s and 60s
because they just put all that energy
into their passion absolutely I mean
there's like there's there's a great
story that I've always looked at too
about like Jay-Z released his first
album when he's 27 years old first album
you know 27 like that you don't hear
about that kind of stuff anymore but
I've always just looked at that as such
like an inspiration that life doesn't
end there you know yeah yeah I'm with it
I think cheesy got to be a little bit
careful about your definition of making
it yeah because
like
Commercial Success like um you know like
even a profile on a on a public media
level like it's a dangerous uh metric
you know compared to just being stoked
on what you do you know like if you're
out there if you want to become famous
and you're like I just want to become
famous or if you if you want to become
rich I just want to become rich yeah
then you're off to a a problematic start
because all you're worried about is the
the end and like so so you don't have a
legitimate reason to to become famous or
Rich yeah but if you're just like it was
so easy for me like I'm just I'm an
attention to where I will do anything to
get people's attention like I started
out from a place of wanting to like
really deserve like that a a significant
reaction from people who see what I do
yeah and so like when you got it by
putting that first then you can get
somewhere but like you just have to
start out with something that you're
genuinely really passionate about I've
always said that it doesn't matter what
you want it only matters how [__] bad
you want it you know it just matters how
bad you want you will move heavens and
earth to to make it happen and if that's
the case then if somebody's that
passionate about something that they
want to pursue
is not going to occur to that person if
they're in their 20s or they're they're
because they're just so ultimately laser
focused on that passion for what they
want to do yeah laid Yeah right when you
so you you've you've definitely
maneuvered through a lot of Life yeah
following your passion yeah has there
been times where you've just like
lost yeah like how old were you when
Jeff Tremaine called you and said like
dude come to L.A chapter man did not
tell me to come down I was living in
Florida and uh that's when I when I
filmed the first uh first season and a
bunch of the seconds really the first
two seasons of Jackass I was in Florida
and uh
when I I got paid for
season two
there's Seasons two and three combined
they I earned thirty thousand bucks
and they were giving me half of that at
the beginning and I would get half of
that when it was done
so after taxes half of thirty thousand
dollars was ten thousand I had a check
coming for ten thousand bucks I called
up tremend and I was like Yo dude I've
never even heard of ten thousand bucks
dude like I'm gonna get this check in
the mail I'm gonna put it in the bank
and before that check even clears into
my bank account I will already be in my
car driving from Florida to California
I was 26 26. and Sherman said you're not
driving anywhere until you give me a
list of ideas for every state between
Florida and California and if your ideas
are there for something to shoot in
every state then I'll send out a crew to
to follow you so I I drove my car and uh
trip Taylor and
um Dimitri road with me in my car trip
Taylor and like uh you know like a crew
a crew followed behind me in a van and I
filmed in every state
but so that's so awesome so that was 26
years old and then when you really
wanted to make it you're probably like
the decision was when you're in
Albuquerque to like
I mean like I dropped out of college
saying I'm gonna become a crazy famous
stunt man in 1993. so like 8 19
um yeah and but that's why I say you got
to be careful about your definition of
making it because in my view like uh in
you know say 1994 1995 I was filming
[__] with my video camera that I was so
stoked on I was like dude people see
this they're like they're [__] blown
away and like and and I'm gonna be dead
but this video will still be playing oh
yeah so I was like dude already boom I
live forever I'm Immortal yeah
because they're constantly filming so
the goal wasn't to be on TV I was like
I'm gonna get even more shits it's gonna
be able to play after I'm dead so I can
cheat death and live forever
yeah I didn't even have to like have any
kind of uh actual success to feel like
I'd made it I was just amped on what I
was doing so is there a definition you
think of making it does that does that
because that's that's kind of what I've
thought of the definition of I think
there's like is feeling like you're
leaving a lot of stuff behind right I
mean well I guess success is like what
financially emotionally spiritually I
guess choose one right yeah so yeah I
mean then you can't Define making it you
definitely cannot we were talking to Dan
Bilzerian on the podcast and he was uh
describing where he was making so much
sense describing like a person's
Baseline whatever your situation is you
get used to it and it doesn't do the
trick for you anymore
you know he's sitting there it's like
the same thing of gaining a tolerance
with drugs right yeah totally yeah 100
doesn't make sense because like you know
when we got there he's like yeah I just
[__] his avian chick it's like dude
you think that guy would just want to be
[__] 47 chicks a night like to get
that thrill like how are you just stoked
on [__] one chick if you're Dan
Bilzerian
the craziest part was when he says like
dude like if I pushed a chick on my
Instagram I'm [__] right here
he's like
he says I mean you don't post a picture
standing next to another man
oh my God have you ever been to one of
his parties back in the day if not have
you yeah wow yeah are they pretty insane
yeah
they're insane I mean it was like right
when I had moved out to California that
I would be going to those parties and it
was just like giant houses and crazy he
took us into his his shower it looked
like a Turkish bath house yeah
it's hard
I loved that guy man like we had a blast
with that guy and get a rock wall above
his pool it's like what though yeah so
cool everything about that dude is
pretty epic how did you link up with
like Dan when you first moved up most
people come to LA to like make it and
they're struggling like you're at
Danville Dan's house I think oh my God
you'll know who this is
no you know who you know who was the the
first person to take me around Hollywood
when I moved out here yes Jeremy Rogers
Jeremy Rogers the skate skater okay yeah
you remember Jeremy Rogers I he was the
young he was super young
Jimmy Rogers was on Plan B was he on
Plan B one point yeah
we gotta talk about Danny Way at some
point yeah anyway stories dude cool yeah
yeah first job I like it you know
I uh I I would be remiss if I didn't ask
you what the hell is a throuple because
it's on your Wikipedia oh is it okay to
ask you that yeah yeah yeah
that was uh that was like that
see see I'm gonna be uh I'm gonna
navigate through this one because I'm
happily engaged so I like to to keep it
right there for sure um but yeah there
was just a crazy time in my life where
um I was dating one girl who was
um basically dating another girl at the
same time and so it existed in that kind
of world yeah all right yeah I think
that was well navigated
I'll I'll leave it this instead of
asking you what is a throttle I will
simply congratulate you
how do you know Danny Way
um so again that was that would be
through the first meeting of Danny Way
would be through Shwayze I would went on
tour with Shwayze before do you know
Cisco Adler nope okay you remember the
group Shwayze nope maybe would you be my
Corona alive you remember that song back
in the day
maybe yeah yeah yeah something like that
yeah that was a rough year for me
that was the year do you remember 2006
there's no music in the k-hole
they're like the most iconic photo of me
was like me laying on the ground in a
pile of whippet containers
oh my God
there's a bunch of photos from that that
might be the craziest face that a human
is ever
that photo Odyssey
um so I met Danny way through them and
then I I was living in Minnesota at the
time but I came out to California
um something fell through and I got to
Hollywood and I had like linked up with
Danny Way
and I called him randomly I was like yo
I got nowhere to go he's like yo come
down to my house so I came down to his
house and I think he was living in San
Diego at the time was it okay and he put
the pigs and then yeah with the pig that
[__] hated me yeah
the pig hated me I think he had two
picks for some reason I was so scared of
that pig
um but dude me and Danny Wade made like
two albums together he produces music
yeah and we like spent I spent like
probably three weeks at his house but we
made like some crazy crazy music and he
was always like one of my Idols growing
up you know I posted him on my wall and
[__] like that
um and uh yeah so I just ended up like
living at his house for a little bit we
still talk all the time and [__] cool
man yeah he's he is definitely uh
one of the first like really
spiritual people that I didn't expect to
be super spiritual cool man yeah yeah
he's uh he's he's always been my hero
yeah for sure I like we're the same age
I was riding a Danny Way skateboard when
we were both 14. oh my God I love it
dude I love it yeah he's a really
special guy oh wait sorry I was 15. we
were 15. okay yeah about that I was
writing a knot
um all right well yeah dude Danny's epic
yeah he signed up on me uh being on XYZ
clothing which was my first sponsor
yeah I mean you don't do anything the
XYZ was Tommy and Danny yeah
yes that's killer yeah I had some XYZ
[__] so uh
you've got our tickets on sale for this
new tour yeah tickets are on sale
modsun.com yeah and and how's the how
are the ticket sales going good good
touring's a whole different world right
now like uh right yeah it's it's yeah so
so basically after covid everyone went
out onto the road and it's still like
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
know all about that yeah you couldn't
get into our bus yeah and like prices
for everything have gone up and everyone
is still like in kind of the honeymoon
period of still being on tour so there's
like a million people on tour at the
same time right
um but yeah it's going really well I'm
about to drop a new album in like uh on
February 3rd so that's God saved yeah I
gotta save the team yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah God save the team how do you
travel around do you do you travel on a
tour bus yeah how many people you you
roll with
huh like probably like 10 to 12. and you
know you guys are all on the same bus
yeah yeah I fill up all the monks yeah I
have a full band with me and then like
crew and [__] like that do you keep the
big room in the back yes yeah you got it
definitely definitely where Chrysler
said that he insists on sleeping in one
of the bunks because he doesn't it's
actually good sleep in the Box
it actually is but I get I feel like I'm
sleeping in a coffin I know but it's
like but it's like actually a good sleep
though it's so just like dark and
confined yeah Vinnie sleeps in in one of
the bunks here you sleep here
nobody's here he sneaks in here yeah
yeah are you familiar with Vincent Yes
yes
well well I I told him I think we've
been in the same room before I guess we
never really like super met but yeah we
have mutual friends I know a good friend
of his name Chad Tupper yeah okay good
yeah yeah all right yeah we like Chad
Tepper yeah
um okay so and you said you're engaged
to be married yeah engaged and can you
talk about with who and you're engaged
yeah yeah to Avril Lavigne yeah boom
just went right there so you're engaged
to Avril Lavigne you know his
relationship sounds like a really good
one and any good relationship has a good
bed babe so what's going on with your
bed is it disgusting is it time to get a
new mattress are you getting the good
sleep that you deserve well the good
news for you is that you can sleep every
bit as well as I'm sleeping lately if
you go to Helix
sleep.com slash Stevo why is it such a
guaranteed thing that you're gonna get a
great night's sleep with Helix sleep.com
well because you take a little two
minute quiz and ma'am you might not even
know what the perfect mattress is for
you but the people at Helix do and get
this up to
350 off your order for the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcast if you go to Helix
sleep.com slash Stevo it's time to get a
new mattress man plus it just comes in
the mail I mean dude no lugging anything
around you just plop that thing on your
bed boom you're ready to go it's sleep
time baby Helix sleep Helix sleep.com
slash Devo and again up to 350 off your
order and you still get two free pillows
plus up to 350 off your order it's
insane get over to helixsleep.com Stevo
on the double and let's get back to it
it's crazy another person that I have
posters on my wall yeah you and me both
yeah
on Instagram
I think you were ice skating yeah and uh
like all of a sudden I'm like he's ice
skating holding hands with Avril Lavigne
and I was like that was kind of a double
take huh and then and then uh and then
it kind of was like wow okay
congratulations mod yeah we met through
we met through making music together so
I worked on her last album with her and
a guy named John Feldman the singer
Goldfinger sure yeah yeah dude feldy's
got to come on here faldi is is an epic
cat yeah that guy is yeah I know him uh
for many reasons oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's a pillar of our community a hundred
percent bro yes he's helped me so much
um so I met her through making music
with her with her which is like
the purest form I would think to meet
someone that you're going to be in a
relationship with because when you're
making music there's like so much you
tell you kind of tell your whole story
to someone while making the music so you
kind of go into the relationship like
really not hiding anything from each
other okay especially a throuple
you didn't talk about the trouble
there's no lyrics about that
we pushed that to the side cleared that
slate yeah I feel like music if you're
gonna do music with with somebody or
like a movie with somebody where two
people like Star they're gonna probably
hook up because it's such a weird
[__] Dynamic that you're in yeah so
uh did you join Avril and Kells on that
like insane Arena tour that they just
had that tour yeah I went out well so we
try to not be apart for too long because
we both go on tour and stuff
um so yeah I went out and visited her
for like two weeks three weeks on that
how nuts was that to her it was crazy
bro did you go see a show I did not oh
it was [__] crazy I bet you would
have loved it because I know you love
like Stadium show I know you love my
crew so much yeah I mean I uh I'm just
obsessed with the idea of
being such a draw that you can sell out
an arena yeah I'm literally obsessed
with that and and um like to an
unhealthy degree I just it's uh
I I describe what I'm doing with my
touring yes marching towards Arenas yeah
like I'm just like everything is just
like how do I build on what I'm doing
and grow and grow until I'm in a Arena
you're totally gonna do it like I I like
to think so yeah and I've got a little
bit of a game plan to get there but um
but as far as going to shows and Arenas
um but again with the weed like I I'm
not like a big concert guy yeah like
I've been to like
two I don't I don't know like like we
went to that uh in Buffalo
and buffalo we went to see One Direction
we didn't go and when this is you know
we met up with Josh Devine you know
beforehand yeah and I mean it's crazy
like Stadium [__] like that the rivers
were flowing with underage beef
the streets turned into rivers
that's right it was like trying to get
to that Stadium
yeah yeah it was in in like to get to
the status where like people are so like
because they said that like people just
pass out left and right during their
show if they see them and it's like to
get to that level it's like the Beatles
level Beatles yeah you know I'm sure
they got even gnarlier Than the Beatles
One Direction I think so
but you know it's crazy that and just
the production like I love seeing
someone create an environment on the
stage I think that's so cool yeah
yeah I mean what other bands have done
stadiums because there's probably only
like a handful I mean less than 50 in
the world that can sell at a stadium
would you say the the stadium in the
arena are different right right so like
Stadium the stadium is stadiums where a
football team yeah yeah and Arenas were
a basketball team plays yeah yeah but I
mean it's like is that safe to say that
there's probably been like under 30
bands that could sell at a stadium
I would think it's more than that
probably like a hundred though but like
not a lot no in the grand scheme of no
music no and especially right now some
of the biggest artists aren't some of
the biggest artists that that are
listened to don't have that same
crossover to people coming to see them
you know it's kind of like uh Chili
Peppers would
I think overseas is a little different I
think overseas there might be more of
like a stadium kind of thing to happen
what would you consider the Forum a
stadium or no an arena in Arena the
forum is for sure yeah that's where the
what about sulfide that's Chinese
Stadium that's a stadium
My Chemical Romance and they sold out
the Forum the farm every night five
nights in a row five nights at The Forum
yeah yeah which so that can probably
would equal to a stadium which is insane
yeah what about like a comedy I mean
who's something like
idioms fluffy did fluffy did what is
that I mean uh Sebastian is Fenway Park
I saw that that's the stadium did he
sell it out I'm sure well that's a lot
crazy I mean that's [__] crazy dude
that much of a draw right
yeah it's crazy dude who are some of
your favorite uh bands at the time at
the moment at the moment I love this
band called The 1975. yeah I think
they're like one of the true like real
bands out right now
um that band Turn Style Turn Style sick
I feel like you might like them dude I
need to get into some new turnstile is
really good yeah
are you familiar with Bam's uh
eavesdroppers album dude I've heard you
talk about it so many times
I've heard you talk about it many times
bro we've got a is it just online or
what no we gotta I don't think you can
get it online that's what that so that's
what the problem was I think I look
tried to look and find it at one point
yeah dude yeah I think we were in Europe
and we just uh we were living on a tour
bus just me and Scott it was this double
decker tour bus Justin Bieber's tour the
last person I was just be Justin Bieber
dude I still haven't been on a double
decker one he sells out stadiums right
Justin Bieber for sure yeah yeah for
sure
you had like 16 buses for his himself
that's like so crazy yeah I mean dude
it's it's outrageous
um and babe I like to do that
tell me what you think about this Theory
uh if somebody asks me what kind of
music do I like and I think that's a
stupid question because with music it's
almost less about whether you like the
music than whether you are familiar with
the music because there's no way around
it if you hear a certain song enough
times then you become invested in that
music that music you have associations
with that music you take the the the
place you are in in your life at the
time the feelings that you're having and
they become bonded with that music
that's why if you hear a song for the
first time in many years it will
literally take you back it will it will
bring back those feelings yeah so we
have associations Jonestown Massacre
so good dude have you seen dig no the
movie yeah wait about about Brian
Jonestown and uh I've heard about the
Dandy Warhols I heard no tell me oh dude
it's like the craziest music documentary
I've ever seen
and Jonestown Massacre were like best
friends at the start and then the Dandy
Warhols went and signed to like a giant
major label got like David La Chapelle
to do a video for him and Jonestown
Massacre said like super underground and
they ended up hating each other but it's
all filmed it's all documented from when
they were best friends it's like
documented over seven years and they
like get into giant fights where dude
was like going outside their concerts
being like the Danny wore all suck and
all it's crazy I love a good documentary
oh it's the it's one of the best music
documentaries I've ever seen dude I
mixed with I have to throw this in have
you seen Searching for Sugar Man oh well
yes that's the one about Rodriguez the
artist Rodriguez I don't think I saw a
documentary what's it about okay yeah
you you have to watch it so I can't like
because like the most it's the most
crazy flip in history of Music it but
it's about an artist yes that I've seen
it that was regarded as like going to be
one of the biggest artists in the world
and then he got something happens yeah
okay now I will walk back what I'm
saying what I said about it's not about
if you like the music because of course
you have to like I love you so much
right your [__] mind is so awesome
you gotta like the music too but because
of this Dynamic where music like uh fuse
it's it's a fusion of your life
experience and this art that you're
consuming you know like you're you're
literally it's like music is is a like a
floppy disk upon which you store your
life experience
and like with that in mind one of my
favorite things that I aspire to do is
to take an album and just listen to
nothing but that album yeah religiously
on repeat on repeat for even weeks on
end and I like to do that if I go on a
on an international trip so that that
trip will always be bonded to that music
so great and it was in Europe I did this
with uh with Bam's eavesdroppers album
so it just takes me back to that trip
yeah I've done that with albums before
too yeah so I I want when when you uh
recommended Turn Style Turn Style 1975
turnston all right Vinnie Vinnie but
like uh Vinnie's a taste maker over here
he's also a real cocksman
you wouldn't think of it how much do you
wave Vinnie uh [__] I gained 20 pounds
on the road uh so I'm up at 290 290.
yeah how much did you lose I lost 130.
wow I didn't ask you that to make you
feel bad no no no for sure yeah I just
like uh it's it's crazy how did you lose
130 pounds
um I just I did keto really gnarly for
like a year yeah I saw myself on camera
for the first time and I almost puked so
I was just like I need to do something
about this that's crazy I've been eating
nothing but beef for the last like month
and a half wow yeah there's this thing
called The Lion diet yeah yeah that's
like super crazy and you notice the
difference yeah
100 really a lot yeah hey let me ask you
um you lived next door to the sublime
drummer yes did you in Long Beach do you
keep in touch with him does he know who
you are does he no I haven't talked to
him in a really long time and it was
like the original drummer of sublime
yeah so not like the one that that would
be known by everyone around the world it
was like the original garage band Yes
yes and that was so when I was in like
11th or 12th grade I think it was 12th
grade I got in a lot of trouble in high
school like my mom just couldn't take it
like I was raised by my mom my sister my
dad lived in Long Beach and my mom
couldn't take it so she sent me out to
live in Long Beach was which was like
even worse the worst idea she's ever had
my dad was getting trouble in Minnesota
moved to Long Beach in the 90s and right
by Cherry Park bro right by Cherry Park
so I was skating all the time like the
Long Beach nines there all that
um but my dad's next door neighbor was
the first person who opened up a
dispensary in Long Beach so basically I
just started like trimming weed farm
when I moved out there and that became
like my job and do you think that
influenced you to be a drummer were you
drumming before that no I was drumming
before that yeah and that's how you guys
that that made me become a giant pothead
definitely at that time yeah were you
smoking before you started cutting for
him yeah yeah a little bit but then it
was like weed in Minnesota compared to
weed in Long Beach California then it
was like a giant leap yeah what kind of
drugs were you doing in Minnesota like
in high school it was really just like I
mean a little bit got a little bit into
cocaine in high school but it was really
just like weed and mushrooms here and
there no never really did pills but this
was also like
2004 in Minnesota weed was
it was like outlawed you know it really
was like it's changed so much now yeah
right but it was like really looked at
as like taboo at that time
um so I was just like skipping school
getting a lot of trouble my mom just
could not like raise me anymore yeah so
she sent me to Long Beach and that was a
turning point
wow
um I'm dying to know like that you do
live in just like a crazy house
it's a beautiful house it's not like a
it's more of like a it's more of like a
beach house right it's like super deep
um and like pretty much on the water and
it's definitely beautiful but like my
girl's also like really like really
clean the opposite of me so it's like
immaculately like set up and and purpose
like that too what's your favorite room
in the house
I'm in our bedroom
yeah bedroom we have like a little
backup Studio that's that's rad too that
I win a lot but would you surf dude I
just start because now now living out
Malibu I'm like forcing myself to I've
never been a beach guy right like I've
lived out in California now for like
eight years and there's never been a
moment where I was like I'm gonna go
chill at the beach today you know like
being from Minnesota I'm such like into
the countryside and into the forest and
[__] like that
um but I started that tried to start
surfing like a year ago and like I was
good like I got up like I could ride it
I just couldn't carve in yet
do you serve I do and and I'm bad at it
well but you get up I can get up yeah
yeah depending depending on that but can
you can you go sideways and carve and
[__] I can I can fire down the line in
the pocket
that's right that's where I'm gonna get
to but I really wanted like it I like
really want to get into something yeah
yeah yeah
fire down the line trying to surf the
river I am we're going up to Bend Oregon
yeah that's gonna be so much fun surfing
you could surf in the river yeah yeah
it's it's a crazy spot it's gonna be so
cool I don't know what how it works if
like you got to pay for a session or
something you'd think yeah you would you
probably have to pay for a pass in the
park and yeah you know it's gonna be
weird
um do you have a life-changing or
favorite book that you read yeah I'll
tell you this and my favorite book it
questions why we put into our bodies
absurd substances posing as food think
about that I mean I put ridiculous
things in my body like uh Rice Krispie
treats okay cookies cake not not good
for you bad nutrition but thankfully
there's ag1 from athletic greens it's
this powder supplement okay one scoop
goes into a pint of water to start my
day which makes me hydrate rated and it
fills the gaps in my diet why because
it's loaded with 75 different
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
superfoods probiotics adaptogens and
it's delicious it's all the nutrition
that you need one stop convenient
comprehensive nutrition and again it's
totally delicious and if you go to
athletic greens.com
Stevo then you can get five
comprehensive daily nutrition travel
packs plus an entire year supply of
immune boosting vitamin D it's the best
deal going it's the best thing for you
that's life-changing so go to
athleticgreens.com
Devo to get this killer deal and not
only is it good for nutrition good for
gut health cognitive health
it's good for everything babe get on
over to athleticgreens.com Stevo let's
get back to it 100 on the road Jack
Kerouac wow okay I haven't read that I
really liked it yeah it I mean it
changed everything like I said like Bob
Dylan be my favorite artist he his life
was like Changed by that book so I like
to like whoever whoever my heroes are I
like to look into like the the rabbit
hole of what inspired them so like that
and then I mean my favorite writer is
probably Charles Bukowski as far as like
the post office and him on rye and I
read all of his stuff yeah I was like a
I I like Charles Bukowski because I was
like a big drunk yeah and I mean to me
like I like romanticized about being
mean like a fall down drunk yep yeah in
like that whole and and plus when like
ham on Ryan the post office is all in LA
and he would bring up things in Pasadena
and like and I would be like yeah I was
just there drinking like crazy and oh
dude the post office I mean
Bros yeah I started reading all those
books right yeah William barrels yeah
but Ham on ride changed my life uh
because I went from hating books to
loving books and I was like man like
this is fantastic and I just started
reading everything I could yeah that's
what on the road did for me yeah and
then and then I I uh
like really on the road got me into
writing books I have six books out right
now and yeah yeah where can they work
where can we get them if you go to
modsound.com and
um like self-published all of them I
have a publishing company that I've done
some books for other people too like
Riff Raff we did a poetry book for him
just pretty legendary yeah yeah rip rap
I follow rip rap on Instagram and I'm
not sure I think he might follow me too
oh I'm sure he does dude I'm sure Riff
Raff loves you another person you should
have on here yeah that would be a great
comment that would be a killer one yeah
cool yeah that'd be great what about you
Benny you have a book that changed your
life dude I don't read
I'm too busy
there's not enough hours in the day
it's crazy I'm just like
you know
before that though would probably be
Ishmael Ishmael was a big one what about
growing up as a kid
um call the wild
I Like My Side of the Mountain
yeah I had this like a crazy fantasy of
running away from home and living off
the land so My Side of the Mountain was
a big one I remember in grade school
they read books too Where the Red Fern
Grows yeah where the red the red Where
the Red Fern Grows to us fifth grade
sounds about right what is conversations
with god dude it's epic Neil Donald
Walsh yeah
Neil Donald wash who we have reached out
to tab on this podcast yeah he's in
Ashland yeah um it's a guy who
um published this book that was on the
New York Times bestseller list for a
record almost three years wow so like
there's something to it but it what it
is he had a
like a
debilitating accident he lost his job he
couldn't like provide for his family he
was just in a place of like severe
frustration and strife and he and he had
a habit of writing letters to people
that he would never necessarily send
this was how he processed things he was
going through yeah and he was in such a
state one day and he just thought ah you
know what like screw it I'm gonna write
a letter to God and it's just like to
prevent his frustrations and just wrote
God like and they go why is my life so
difficult like why is you know like all
this stuff and the story is that as he
wrote this he intuitively got a response
which was do you really want questions
to these or do you really want answers
to these questions or are you just
venting and so he wrote down these these
answers that he was intuitively getting
and that became this
this dialogue so it's it's a dialogue
between him and God and he writes writes
it all down and it's like a kind of a
tough pill to swallow and a lot of
people would call it blasphemy yeah to
suggest that this guy is you know
writing the words of God but
as difficult as that is keep in mind
this book was on the New York Times
bestseller list for almost three years
yeah I think it's like 140 weeks or
something like it's a record I believe
and
it absolutely changed my life it
fundamentally changed the way I view the
universe and I say it all the time and I
love it and it was a Trilogy book one
two and three oh until you gotta check
it out so book one is about like that
for the individual like book two is uh
for like Humanity maybe or whatever then
book three is like the whole well we saw
him and uh he was writing book number
four he did he was promoting book number
four yeah I mean the guys put like 20
books out now yeah but the cool thing is
like an audio version yeah because on
the on the uh on book one on the audio
or I guess of both of them God's voice
switches from a man to women like just
randomly throughout oh that's cool it's
super cool oh that's cool yeah I'm gonna
check that out it's it's epic it's super
Epic
yeah what else do we want to talk about
man you guys have been killer Vinnie's
doing a great job Vinnie you have
anything the
all right so all right Tepper was
telling me a story about uh when's the
first time Zach asked met you yeah and
uh you guys were pranking Zach because
you're like Zach don't look mad son in
the eyes oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah and like Zach like accidentally
looks you in the eyes and you just
started freaking out oh yeah I committed
to the big yeah yeah which was really
hard for me to do I really don't do [__]
like that with people and I was just
like I freaked out on him I remember
that that was the first time I met him
yeah Zack ass is awesome bro I think it
was at my house yeah I think it was at
my house Chad Tepper was living with me
for a little bit yeah yeah that's funny
yeah I talked to Tapper today he's like
bring up that story
nice you guys put that on Instagram or
something right I don't know if they did
yeah I don't think so Zach has been
killing it man yeah it's so fun to see
yeah it's great what you guys did with
everyone bringing all the new kids in
and [__] well thanks man yeah yeah we
should all meet up to Malibu surf bro
please please come hang out with me in
Malibu I need friends out there I
definitely do yeah yeah I I I'm trying
to uh get my exercise game on so I gotta
get my exercise just up I'm back on it I
was just up in the hills above wait I
thought it was a leaf blower it's a
legit Chainsaw
the noise level you're gonna turn it on
I'm sorry Wendy I didn't mean to do that
okay
he like accidentally hit my ankle dude
it would not be right if I came on here
and you didn't turn a chainsaw on and
have a machete yeah dude thank God what
what were you doing I was clearing
juggling them yeah
sorry wounded good girl
um the the trail had the the cacti the
the same cacti that Zack ass rode the
skateboard down and he went into the
that's back there yeah it said it's the
cacti like was grown all into the path
so it's like hard to hike all the way up
to the Hollywood Sign yeah without
um getting thorns in here yeah so I was
clearing away the
and dude every time I go up there it
reminds me that the gnarliest stunt ever
was Zack ass going into those cacti bro
you consider that the gnarliest one ever
I mean dude that's a heavy station
yeah in that same position yeah I would
have done so you ought to recreate fire
Angels
five maybe fire Angels ended up being
gnarlier it ended up being gnarlier but
like the anticipation
would be probably the cactus then
because I know it's gonna suck
it's a tall statement since the
gnarliest stone ever but dude that dude
it's heavy going into those Cactus yeah
dude
yeah you said it was stuck and you were
trying to get and then he was like
trying to get accident out or something
like that well dude he was trying to get
out of it and like he was like putting
his hand down on other cactuses to get
out so he's like ah like every movement
he would make instinctively to get out
of the situation it would just keep
[__] dude it was gnarly dude
but yeah I'll take you up there man it's
epic oh yeah I gotta see it let's see
Brad what size shoe are you like nine oh
you're a nine and a half 10.
like uh that's that same as me yeah
sorry you wouldn't you wouldn't do too
well trying to get up there in those
combat boots oh I'll do it I'll do it
we'll be good sick and then like you
know we get up there you can take an
epic photo with the Hollywood sign it's
right there I mean yeah it's like kind
of in the background but but yeah it's
just it's sick so you do you like living
over here I love it yeah love it plus
this hike is like the best thing about
the whole deal yeah there's a little
secret at the top yeah
all right speaking of shoes yeah
ah well do you want to do that or do you
want to do it I'm going to include that
in the same all right well speaking of
shoes on my part I'm going to give away
another pair of shoes okay we might as
well announce that nobody did anything
impressive to earn your Nike Air Jordan
I know dude so many coups
I said in a creative way and people were
reaching out to me on LinkedIn people
would DM my brother people with DM
Knoxville I mean there's nothing
creative about it so uh so so I asked
Scott like who who's who won like what
was the baddest thing and Scott says
nobody did anything even remotely
creative so I thought to myself what
would I do
if I wanted to win the shoes and I was
like oh well I would like
get like a you know a green sheet and
and uh you know like climb like like I'm
gonna make it with a green screen that I
was climbing out of the shoe and then I
would
edit you know in the editing I'd make
myself become a big giant and then pick
up the shoe and and say thanks Scott
Randolph for the yeah you know like and
so I did it like super easy yeah and the
video was rad too I did it in literally
one take and you also brought out a guy
to help film then I thought that lux
called me off she said that uh that it
wasn't fair because I was using
sophisticated editing and green screens
so you won not everybody has access to
that so I tried to do another version
where uh there was no green screen it
was just a depth perception thing yeah I
climbed up the shoe and then jumped into
it and I did it but it was lame okay so
then okay so then you won because you
actually did it I won yeah people would
say it's rigged but it's not you
actually did the video and I gave it
yeah I blew it out I won by a mile
there's
I'm an animal guy and they're made out
of leather so what are you gonna do with
them I'm gonna uh I'm gonna post a video
with showing what I did to win the shoes
and now that uh they're mine I'm gonna
invite people to win the shoes from me
without
harassing all of our Associates and
loved ones
unsolicited messages like uh that would
turn into a nightmare you were like get
a hold of me everybody you know
everybody I know Knoxville's
screenshotting like hey this [__] guy
messaged oh my God oh my God I'm so
sorry dude
everybody's bugging everybody about I
don't want anybody reaching out to
anybody else just do your creative thing
and tag me
yeah there you go hey man you know I go
through my Instagram
tags you know I I see all that and and
while we're while we're in the spirit of
giving things away I have some Kyrie
Irvings that I don't want
am I saying that right Kyrie Irving yeah
are they Nikes yes okay so I have Nike
Kyrie Irvings they're like the floral
print and where did you get those I'm a
shoe head dude
yeah you're a sneaker there you go let's
have a sneaker head now and the way to
win this one it's really near and dear
to my heart if you go to walmart.com and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and screenshot the proof of purchase
with a five-star review you might have a
chance to win wow but if you can't get a
hold of me on social media because I'm
off so go ahead and tag Steve in it and
Steve will pick the winner I'll say this
any tag or any post I see that shows a
five-star review for a
proven purchase of hot sauce for your
butthole I will double tap that I mean I
double tap everything that I see
especially at walmart.com because that's
gonna be big I mean anytime somebody
buys merch from stevo.com and posts
anything with it like not without fail I
always double tap that okay problem is
that people don't understand that I
don't see it if they just put my handle
in the in the caption yeah yeah you have
to actually tag yeah because uh the
volume of stuff like I just I don't see
the you gotta I see everything that I'm
tagged in properly all right and then
how do people go get tickets to the mod
Sun tour that's modsun.com
we're gonna we're gonna add a little
link there as well
um
mod sun stands for movement on dream
stand under none so yeah modsumn.com
movement on dream stand under none yeah
I like that dude yeah killer man I like
it [__]
I am a fan of the podcast and just just
uh I do I do have a question whether
whether you leave this in or not but
like so I'm three years eight months
seven days sober without drinking or
drugs uh no no weed so that's been about
like a year and a half okay wow congrats
dude
so like it's to me you know it just it
really seems to be getting more
difficult okay right and um
was there did did you go through that
similar around this time
um and is there just like
I am a big fan of the 12-step process
right and I think that that it's
demonstrable the you know
validity of it because millions and
millions of people have come before us
yeah and uh you know basically the proof
is in that yeah you know like there's a
book which outlines the 12-step process
and it nobody's ever tried to rewrite it
nobody you know like there's just one
book since 1939. yeah and then you know
that the consensus is they got it right
and the people who uh followed that book
so the book outlines the 12-step process
and the the point at which I believe the
obsession to drink alcohol and take
drugs is lifted comes when one completes
a thorough fifth step
I think that that like uh just going by
that you know like that step four is
where you make an inventory of
everything that that uh
upsets you and and like it's pretty
incredible the way everything that I've
said to you
falls into three categories there's
resentment
you know if you're like just pissed off
somebody then that that's upsetting
there's fear
and there's guilt so so the the
inventory process well Harm's done to
others that that brings guilt you feel
guilty because you harm somebody fair
enough yeah so uh so you make a a list
of everything that you can think of that
you feel resentful about
you make a list of everything you can
think of that you feel fearful about you
make a list of everything you can think
of that you feel guilty about and then
uh yeah you know you take these lists
that's step four you take these lists to
somebody and you talk through it all
with them okay get it all off your chest
and the idea is that you break down
what your part is in the resentments you
break down what like appropriate
indicated action you can do to address
your fears and in this process you
really dismantle everything that screws
you up you you take the power out of
everything that upsets you and once
you've once you've done that like you
don't like that the edge is taking off
like everything that you're using the
drugs Now call to soothes is soothed
yeah so so yeah I think the difference
is that like if you haven't done that
and you're not drinking or doing drugs
you're like what they say is like white
nothing and so it's like that stuff's
still inside of you you're just not
covering it up anymore so it probably
will get harder yeah and just maybe
eating you alive and then when you do
take the power to that or like when you
let go of like a secret and like telling
somebody
that takes a lot of the power out of it
too and then for me when I did that like
my life got better and better
it but up until that point I was sober
it's just like it's like I had an
infection inside of me and I wasn't
taking I wasn't numbing out to like to
be distracted by it like I was finally
not doing drugs and then like the
infection was like oh [__] it's like
painful inside yeah it just kept getting
more painful and painful and I think the
steps is like cutting you open doing the
work is like you know having a doctor
kind of clean you out and Stitch you
back up and getting the infection out
I've heard people say I never suffered
from alcoholism until I got sober yeah
right and that's like uh because
because the
the the drinking alcohol and taking
drugs is not the disease that is if
anything a remedy disease yeah that's a
symptom of the disease the disease is
centered in our mind and the
characteristics of the disease are
restless irritability discontent like
we're just plain uncomfortable in our
own skin and we need to to soothe that
discomfort so we cover it up with drugs
and alcohol you take away the drugs and
alcohol
you still have the disease so you got to
do something to to address that
discomfort to dismantle the the ills of
the disease and that's where the
inventory process comes you literally do
an inventory of everything that makes
you uncomfortable
and it's it's the raddest thing it is
it's super red was the fourth really
difficult for you oh my God I I got the
fourth step blues and landed up in a
psych ward oh really yeah
I was in I went back and forth between
steps four and five you know I would
write out a bunch I would go and then
talk through it I'd go back and write
more I'd go back now were you for the
fourth were you going back as far as you
could like of course as long as you
remember yeah yeah yeah yeah well yeah
well no because at first I was just like
dude that was [__] eight years old
but that's where like somebody you know
what do they say if it's hysterical it's
historical so it's like it comes from
somewhere for sure but yeah every time I
would go to my sponsor to do the fifth
and and he would be like no like you
need to go you need more you need to go
back further yeah because the more the
more data that you can crunch the more
effective the process is yeah like you
get out of it what you put in so if
you're like really thoroughly put in
everything that's ever bothered you into
it yeah and what's great about doing the
this this process is that
as you get into it as you break down all
of the these things on your inventory
patterns emerge and you realize oh my
God like I always trip myself up
by doing this should you identify
patterns you identify behaviors which
don't serve you and you can they call it
uncovered discover discard and you just
kind of let go but the problem I had and
why I wound up in the psych ward for the
second time with three months of
sobriety
I am had
in my you know in my inventory I just
put down like I I was I was looking at
things that I had done that that I just
felt like a terrible person for having
done but in my my harm done others
inventory the things I felt guilty about
and I just arrived at the conclusion
that I was a terrible person and did not
deserve forgiveness and that the only
thing that was going to work was I had
to kill myself [__] yeah and uh and then
I was at a you know one of our meetings
and I'd shared that I said all the work
I'm putting into my steps I feel like
I'm just getting out self-hatred I just
feel like I hate myself I can't forgive
myself and I just want to blow my brains
out now how long did that yeah yeah I
was three months sober at that time but
how long did that feeling last that
self-hatred from doing that um well I I
that that meeting took place on Hospital
grounds that had a psych ward on those
the the good people of the group just
they lovingly walked me across the
grounds to the psychord right you said
you want to kill yourself yeah yeah and
and I was with it I was like hey I need
to be in here yeah so I checked myself
into that psych ward they're like pill
boys back
while I was in that psychord and I
couldn't get out for like three weeks
but while I was in there I was reading
that same book which is uh you know
which outlines the 12 steps and um
there's a chapter in that book
um
which I was I was reading it and uh it
says that the the history of every
alcoholic is plagued with specters of
the United things every alcoholic has a
history of uh of things that they've
done they're humiliating tragic you know
like sad even like it's like funny you
know but like but like the the the sum
total of any alcoholics past
like is comprised of a lot of stuff that
that you would think
you gotta like it says one would think
that the past of an alcoholic that that
for that future happiness was dependent
upon forgetfulness of the past like you
could never be so ashamed of what you've
done in your past that you can never be
happy in your future unless you're able
to swipe it on or the rug load it up
into the closet throw away the key and
never think about it ever again if
you're going to be happy after you've
done all that crap it says but art and
it says but our history shows the exact
opposite that in fact the the tragic
humiliating you know like upsetting the
past of the alcoholic is actually the
like uh the one of the greatest if not
the absolute greatest asset to the
alcoholic because having overcome that
terrible past
now the alcoholic is equipped to help
other people overcome their own past by
Rising above it moving forward moving
past it now we can we can help others do
the same that's why the the book says uh
no matter how far down the scale we have
gone well like uh
that we'll see how our past can be
useful to others so in that reading of
that I was reading that book I'm in the
psych ward I just think I'm a terrible
it just kind of clicked for me like oh
maybe
like
all this awful crap that I did which I
feel so just terrible about and I feel
like I can't forgive myself maybe the
answer isn't to kill myself maybe the
answer is to just stop being that
terrible person like that's what the
inventory process is for is yeah uncover
discover discard like maybe I just let
go of that that's the whole point don't
dwell on like how ashamed I am but just
stop being that stop doing that and so
when I got out of that psych ward I
checked myself back into rehab again I
started over from scratch and and I just
took the the position that I don't want
to be that guy anymore and and that then
I I shifted my
my motivation my perspective and ever
since then
it's and really that that same shame of
bit of all that crap I did became the
fire under my ass to to stay sober for
the right reasons what are you thinking
about when he says that
that is just like a great example for me
to know I mean first off that like I
didn't do the steps I haven't done the
steps so like first off I think that
that's like the real big move that I
need to do
the second is that like you seem to have
this
idea that
see like my my biggest cons my biggest
thing that keeps [__] with my head is
that I'm at the point now where it's
almost like the there was like a high
from
getting sober and proving to myself that
I could do that and it seems like that
somehow running low and now I feel like
I'm like was
more interesting or more fun or
something
being [__] up and I know I know that's
wrong I know that's wrong and I can say
it out loud it's just about I need to
convince myself and I just look at what
you're saying with like you have this
real passion behind you that like I mean
you've lived one of the craziest lives
of anyone I've ever known that part was
easy for me because
looking at my professional career
before I got sober like I put a lot of
work into developing a skill set that I
could utilize for you know the the style
of entertainment that you know that I
became known for yeah I put a lot of
effort into it there was like some
legitimate skill behind it there was a
lot of creativity there was like there
was it wasn't just dumb you know there
was there was work and there was
creativity and it gradually as I got
worse on with drugs and alcohol it
devolved and by the end I I mean I was
just look how wasted I am like Oh and it
was like Stevo peed on this you know
like it was just where could I be
inappropriate pull out my Wayne or pee
on something like a Stevo peed on a red
carpet you know like Stevo's smoked pot
here like
there was just like it was on an
airplane right down an airplane it just
became kind of pathetic that like that
like gone was the real creativity gone
was the like the the effort like the it
just became a sad pathetic guy you know
and um it's scary to get sober but I
mean
I'm way I've demonstrated like many
times over
to like to the power of the nth degree
that I'm far more creative for sure and
fun yeah and sobriety than I was
particularly at the end of my run with
drugs and alcohol yeah
yeah so I mean
I would submit to you that if you feel
like you're going to be more fun
creative interesting on drugs and
alcohol
I mean in our literature it says
head on over to the nearest bar room and
see what happens you know like
um
I I have trouble believing that that uh
there's gonna be any
yeah because if I think about drinking
I'm not thinking about like drinking I'm
thinking about getting [__] up and
like I was talking with my therapist and
I said man dude like I just wish I could
be normal and drink like a six pack of
beer at night and chill
um it's funny that like you think that's
normal
but like it's not and she's like that's
you're thinking like I like I want I
fantasize about getting I don't
fantasize about enjoying the hit of weed
and it's like I just fantasize about
being [__] blazed on the beach all
day like that's what I think about you
know it's not enjoyable I think about
the most extreme of like that's
swallowing and being a fall down drunk
yeah what you know and like I'm falling
asleep in a dumpster yeah I like it yeah
romanticize yeah you were talking about
like Bukowski yeah you know
I want to be so like crazy on drugs that
I haven't slept for three days and then
like people walking around who aren't
actually there yeah
you think about the fifth day how fun
that would be you know it's like yeah my
thinking's off yeah right and the other
thing too that like uh
people who are not alcoholic never
wonder if they're alcoholic you know
like yeah I'm not sure but you know well
no it's like you know how somebody's an
alcoholic if it's like my sister's a
normian and if I was like when was the
last time you drank she's like uh like
four months ago yeah I'm like hey mod
when's the last time you drank your like
three years seven days six hours
[Laughter]
exactly bro exactly yeah Sami I don't
know I mean like the other thing too
and this is I say this a lot that
in my view the worst situation to be in
is to
kind of be alcoholic yeah you have
alcoholism but not too bad yeah because
in that situation there's no like black
and white definite like need to address
it and because there's not that it's not
that bad it can go on and and it does go
on because it's not that bad so it just
you never do anything about it and like
you're it it's just bad enough to slow
you down to compromise your ability to
accomplish your goals you're talking
about like the functioning addict yeah
like eating soup with a fork it's just
it's just bad enough to interfere with
your relationships to make you not
realize your potential yeah you know but
not bad enough that it's got to stop so
it continues and and you know in years
slip through your fingers and then the
years turn into decades and next thing
you know you're you're like old and you
think damn I blew it yeah as opposed to
if you have alcoholism so dramatically
badly that it has to be addressed and
that was the boat I landed in very lucky
to land in that boat because I was 33
years old and I had to do something
about it yeah now I'm coming up on 15
years of not being impeded by drugs and
alcohol you know and by like you know
for 15 years I've largely been able to
focus my energy and my ability on what I
want to do now of course to Scott's
point that like chasing [__] around it
like really impedes one's ability to
accomplish their goals but then I
addressed that too and now I've got I've
got this great relationship with my girl
and like there's no distraction so I'm
like a laser just like
you know like laser focused and
nothing's in my way wasting my time or
and so like to me
that's the yeah the ultimate people like
when they talk about you know Heaven
hell or like Purgatory like the in
between like my definition of hell would
be
being high as [__]
with another person that's high as [__]
talking about like dreams like you know
I can't wait to do this like that would
be my definition of hell oh dude I was
just sitting here okay dude like yeah
we're gonna do this we'll do that and
then it's like or being 50 or 60 talking
about the Glory Days you know it's like
right now in my life it's it's full and
there's goals and there's things to look
forward to on a daily basis like that's
why I got sober I I one of the things I
talk about is I try really really
[__] hard to travel the world when I
was getting [__] up and like I maybe
did like 10 countries you know and I was
like broke and I was just kind of like
I'd be in Germany sleeping on the floor
you know on a park bench with a
newspaper over me or like just [__]
staying at a shitty hostel and trying to
work for two weeks to you know an IRA
whatever and then when I got sober
uh anyway [__] we've been to like 40
countries together you know it's just
kind of like things just happen so
easily where it's like I I have it's
like it's not like when I try my hardest
to do something when I'm [__] up and
I'm in the wrong State of Mind like I
said eating soup with a fork it's like
you're just working so hard to [__]
not get full and then once you kind of
like just give up and be like all right
[__] it I Surrender [__] just pops off
pops off yeah you know so yeah we're big
fans of sobriety
I mean my whole life changed when when
when I changed it really did yeah and
then you met the one yeah well that that
100 that and then I mean just everything
in my life I mean just my mom being like
I look at you and I feel like I have my
son back you know what I'm saying was
was like a big thing but there was just
such a and this is what I need hearing
all this is so great because
like I said and it's probably I mean you
guys could tell me it's probably the
wrong way to think about it is that like
there was so much
um like like I said like a high attached
to the fact of proving to myself that I
could do it
um whereas yeah so that and yeah that's
I gotta be done with that right and and
just realize that it's more to it than
just the proving to myself here's the
thing I think this is probably the most
I feel broken like at this point right
now with just like not knowing
here how to move forward like everything
felt like I was moving forward at such a
great rate and I just like don't want to
end that
um
whether
one is an alcoholic or not take take
that completely aside and we're not
talking about addiction on any level
we're just talking about being a human
being okay I think that most people's
biggest problem is that they have not
identified the thing that they are just
ultimately passionate about because it
is impossible to hit a bullseye if you
are not aiming at a Target and a lot of
people just don't have they don't have a
purpose they don't have that thing that
they want to do and so without
identifying a goal it's impossible to
accomplish a goal so people are just
kind of wandering through life without
like a goal and that's the biggest
problem I think
um you know you gotta identify what it
is that you're passionate about and then
life takes on this this uh this magical
purpose and this opportunity to be
fulfilled that otherwise you can't have
so
for you I I hear you saying that that uh
you know life is like you know the the
high of proving to myself that I could
live without drugs and alcohol is kind
of wearing off and now I'm wondering am
I more more interesting if I pick up
drugs Now call again and I would say
that probably number one you wouldn't be
thinking that if uh if there wasn't some
danger there and number two I think you
could eradicate that entire line of of
thought by just
like
recommitting yourself to identifying
your purpose you know like if you if you
just sit down if you just ask yourself
I'm getting ready to go on this epic
tour got a new album coming out like
what where is the void coming from you
know like are you concerned that that
now that you've got this album out like
that that now you need creative juices
to start writing the next album and so
you're insecure about that admit to
making you question your sobriety like
you know like get to the root of what
the concerns are yeah the why and just
keep asking why yeah and I mean
lean into it yeah I would say you know
and and if
if you feel like you you've got more
experimenting to do they that you need
to go out there and and get loaded smoke
a joint you know like whatever it is
just uh
be careful maybe not even be careful but
just be be ready to identify
like uh just a loop of of
counterproductive yeah [__] you know
Groundhog's Day yeah of loserville
yeah
I mean yeah I mean maybe you're maybe
you're not an alcoholic maybe you're not
you know there's only one way to find
out and that's just crash and burn but
like but my concern would be that only
having alcoholism a little bit so it
just goes on forever and just slows you
down and just makes your life less than
completely [__] awesome
yeah so ask yourself what what is your
vision for your life to be the maximum
completely [__] awesome that it can
be and then
draw your road map to that being your
reality and let nothing [__]
interfere with the the
[__] mission to make it down that
path and be that awesomeness
yeah and I don't think they're getting
[__] starved and [__] up like even
like as part of that path no dude it's
not it's not and I I mean I I got I
cleaned up completely because of almost
dying from an overdose there you go I'm
like so I know where it leads me was it
just one overdose that that did it for
you yeah and you were like I don't want
to do that anymore yeah yeah see it
wasn't cocaine that wasn't it man that's
a scary overdose yeah I mean it was it
was a like seven day Bender mixed with
you know
a couple other things along the way but
yeah so people hadn't been walking
around at that point yeah even though
we're not there yeah yeah
we'll do we'll we'll leave it with that
dude like ask yourself what's the
[__] awesomest version of my life
that I can possibly make real and uh and
let that be the the north star that
guides your next steps
dude thank you yeah I mean thank you dog
yeah yeah that was great yeah really
appreciate it hell yeah for sure
did I tell you that last half an hour
was wild or what man it's the most we've
gotten really into it about uh addiction
and Recovery maybe ever and uh after
that mod sun and I went hiking playing
with the chainsaw this is blast I'm
rooting for that guy I love that kid and
uh Hey ma'am I love you too the people
who stick around to the end of the
podcast my beloved street team please do
give my son some love and love yourself
and each other too yeah